un baleineau d'un mois sur une plage de
la floride une nécropsies tentera de
vérifier si ces blessures sont celles
d'un bateau de pêche sportive au qu'une
baleine noire n'est mort dans les eaux
canadiennes en 2020 n'empêche le déclin
de l'espèce se poursuit les experts
estiment et la population à 400 baleines
l'an dernier il y en aurait maintenant
366 quand tout d'entrée elle sera perçue
dans le golfe du saint laurent durant la
saison de pêche pêches et océans canada
fermera la zone de 2000 kilomètres
carrés neuf jours plus tard
si elle y est toujours la zone restera
fermé pour le reste de la saison
auparavant c'était aujourd'hui qu'on
agisse et attendre un peu pour s'assurer
que c'est pas seulement une baleine qui
transitent dans le cadre d'une attaque
qui est déjà fermé mais que c'est une
baleine ou des baleines qui se
regroupent deux firmes et de façon
définitive du territoire de pêche très
important au début de la saison de pêche
1 pour nous c'était une mesure abusive
l'an dernier les pêcheurs de crabes
spécialement des communautés rurales et
francophones du nouveau brunswick estime
avoir perdu 400 millions de dollars
ce sont de nombreux contingents de crabe
des neiges qui ne sont pas capturé ils
ne sont pas livrés dans les usines de
transformation
donc ce n'est pas énorme au niveau des
économies mais si les mesures ne sont
pas assez stricte les etats unis
menacent de boycotter les produits
canadiens
on se doit de protéger notre accès au
marché américain qui est qui absolument
de première importance à la fois pour
laurent que pour le cas on n'a pas
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre avec les
baleines noires puisque je vois des
mesures qui sont adoptés s'est
définitivement on ne fait le pari de la
prudence je salue ce geste là s'il y
avait un peu d'espoir il s'est vite
dissipé 15 belenos on est cette année
mais déjà deux d'entre eux sont morts et
six mondes montambault radio-canada
moncton